I wouldn't be able to pay this off until
I'm 70.
the choices John may have to make for
his family are Stark with two children
and a mortgage due for Renewal next
summer his best offer right now is
paying 3 000 pounds to exit his current
deal and then 700 pounds extra a month
on top you have to make huge decisions
like do we sell our house you know this
was meant to be our
Family House forever you know I couldn't
imagine his leaving in a lovely area
it feels like the government gambling on
all our homes at the moment with
mortgage rate hikes on the way lenders
are continuing to pull their deals off
the market money facts has seen its
highest ever daily fall in available
deals dropping by 935 on Tuesday more
than double the previous record daily
fall of 462 in April 2020 at the start
of lockdown on Wednesday the number of
mortgage deals on the market had gone
down 32 percent compared to last Friday
it's changing massively so for example
last night I did an application for a
customer and as I was going through on
the lender's website it sort of crashed
and the rate actually changed this
morning over the course of the five
years that we're looking at so it can
make a huge impact over the time
economists warn as a result growing
borrowing costs May trigger a steep fall
in house prices and according to some by
as much as 10 to 15 percent next year so
that's mortgage affordability Rising
inflation the risk of recession
altogether potentially triggering a
housing market crash now up until a week
ago that would have been a worst case
scenario but now some analysts believe
that it could be the most likely outcome
but there are still no certainties the
housing market is not immune from big
economic hits It's almost like the
housing market might pause for the next
few weeks basically as everyone just
stands back the difference between
whether prices are flat or fall a lot is
all about how long mortgage rates stay
high for how long
um I think if rates suddenly start
quickly coming back down to four percent
in the next month or so then we're going
to see much just slower house price
growth everything hinges on what the
government and Bank of England do next
and crucially how quickly or slowly they
move in Adele Robinson Sky News